where we left off in the last video in
1924 Hitler was in jail his coup d'etat
1923 his famous beer hall pooched in
munich had failed he's now in jail he's
writing mine Kampf when he gets out of
jail so this is when he's in jail the
Nazi Party is banned and a lot of the
economic turmoil that made the
possibility of overthrowing the
government more likely as that we saw in
the early twenties that hyperinflation
in Weimar Germany this was now under
control by the time Hitler comes out of
jail they had issued new currency it was
far more stable so to a certain degree
they were the Nazis and Hitler were
starting from scratch although even at
this point Hitler continues to be an
ever growing influence he's a famous
speaker there are more and more people
who are knowing about him who were
following him over the next few years
his book does get published and it's it
sells actually tens of thousands of
copies over the next several years but
for the most part he's still a
relatively small actor in German
politics but then we fast-forward as we
get to the late 20s the Nazis are
gaining some influence but then in 1929
in 1929 you have a global change for for
the economy of the world and that's the
beginning of the Great Depression in
particular what's often kind of the the
first sign that the Great Depression was
at hand is you have the US stock market
crashes in October of 1929 famous black
Tuesday and that was the mark of the
beginning of a not just a American
depression but a global depression so
bring you have the whole world going
into depression and anytime you have
economic turmoil it tends to give more
energy to the more extreme parties
whether it is the parties like the Nazis
who one could consider maybe to be on
the extreme right are often considered
to be on the extreme right or very high
or maybe you could say very
nationalistic or even the extreme left
parties who are obviously against
capitalist systems and and whatever else
and so by the election of 1930 and now
we're talking about parliamentary
elections and the Parliament in Germany
is the rice tag the rice rice tag and I
know I'm mispronouncing it
in the Reichstag elections the Nazi
Party for the first time is able to have
a significant showing it gets 18 it gets
roughly 18 percent of the vote and a
proportional representation in the
parliament so now all of a sudden this
kind of marks the beginning of the Nazis
being significant significant players in
German politics then we get to 1932 and
the economy is not improving it's only
getting worse
1932 Adolf Hitler actually makes a run
for president the current president at
that point is paul von hindenburg famous
for the Hindenburg Line later for the
Hindenburg the Zeppelin the famous
exploding Zeppelin disaster and he was
with Ludendorff one of the two leaders
of the German military effort during
World War one he's president of the
Weimar Republic since 1925 and in 1932
he is able to get re-election but Hitler
has a has a fairly good showing Hitler
is able to get 35% of the vote Hitler
gets 35% of the presidential election
votes of the vote and the Weimar
Republic had the strange system it
wasn't quite a presidential system like
the US and it wasn't quite a pure
parliamentary system like the current
day Germany the president was
independently elected and had some
powers and then the Parliament was also
independently elected and then they
would try to build coalitions to have a
ruling government but needless to say
1932 Hitler is now a major actor the
Nazis also have a many many many seats
in parliament now you have several
parliamentary elections as well in 1932
and as we just talked about two in
particular in order for a government to
form in parliament in order to find the
cabinet and the chancellor who is
essentially the prime minister you have
an election and the different parties
get different amounts of votes and if no
party has a majority the parties have to
form a coalition that can make a
majority and so there's a lot of horse
trading going on with parties
negotiating hey why don't we form a
coalition with each other if we do that
maybe someone from my party can be
Minister of the Interior some of your
someone of your
party could be the Chancellor and maybe
we can get a coalition together to rule
over the government but you have two
parliamentary elections and no majority
coalition forms so two two elections so
this is parliamentary so this is in the
presidential election Hindenburg is
still president
but Hitler has a good showing and then
you have two parliamentary elections
Parliament elections or rye stag
elections where you have no majority no
coalition no majority majority coalition
and the Nazis continue to be a major
actor here they continue to get have
more and more of a showing inside the
rice tag so then by 1933 it's a bit of a
crisis so as we get into early 1933 we
have a little bit of a crisis we have no
government we have a no Chancellor we
have no cabinet to essentially be the
executive the government - of the
country because there has been no major
coalition and the Weimar Constitution
allowed a strange thing it allowed the
President to appoint a government
appoint a cabinet a chancellor that
might not even be representative of
what's going on in Parliament and so
paul von hindenburg is convinced that
hey look and he was no fan there's you
know that he was no fan of Adolf Hitler
but he's convinced that look Adolf
Hitler was your opponent if you make
Adolf Hitler the head of an interim
government the head of an interim
cabinet then that might be a way to
create some national unity and and then
maybe we could have some parliamentary
elections that there can be a majority
coalition and you could have I guess you
could say a more legitimate government
take hold and so paul von hindenburg is
convinced and so he does even though
even though the Nazis are still a
minority party even though they weren't
part of any type of a majority coalition
paul von hindenburg who's not a fan of
Adolf Hitler appoints him as Chancellor
so this is in January so in January
Hitler Hitler is appointed Chancellor
Chancellor which is essentially the
Prime Minister of the rice tag of the of
of Germany and then we get to February
and events get really really really
interesting so in February of 1933 you
have a fire in the Reichstag building in
Berlin so this is the rice tag building
right over here and it is on fire and
they find this gentleman here on the
scene marinus van der Lubbe he's a dutch
communist it is essentially the blame is
placed as this was some type of a the
beginning of some type of a communist
revolution and this is used as a pretext
Hitler then advises pond
Paul von Hindenburg to essentially use
some of his emergency powers as
president - which is another strange
thing that the Weimar Constitution
allowed for it allowed the president
under emergency conditions to start to
suspend civil rights this was an
emergency situation and so you paul von
hindenburg does that so he essentially
issues and you so once you have the you
have the ricetec fire rise tag fire and
then Hindenburg is convinced by the
Nazis to pie to pass the Reichstag the
rush tag fire decree fire decree which
essentially suspends it gives the
government emergency powers and it
suspends civil liberties which
everything up to this point now is
actually legal this was actually allowed
for in the Weimar Constitution suspends
suspends civil civil liberties and since
there is no coalition the whole point
that that Hitler's cabinet was going to
be an interim one you have another you
have another parliamentary election
coming in March it with the with the
hope of maybe a majority coalition forms
but that March election especially with
civil liberties suspended you could
imagine that the Nazis and they have
their there ed they're kind of their
store they're their paramilitary
troopers started intimidating other
parties making sure that they had a
better showing at the polls they started
intimidating other candidates the march
election start to swing hugely in the
Nazis favor so in the March election
they're able to get 44% of
the vote which is still not enough by
themselves to form a government it's
still not a majority but they are able
now this is a there there now the
largest party in the Reichstag in the
parliament they're able to now form a
majority coalition and I guess you could
say more legitimately although this was
a election of intimidation they were
able to now they're able to now form a
government they're able to now form a
government based on a majority coalition
and Hitler remains Chancellor but then
this new Parliament passes the enabling
act in March enabling act enabling act
which is essentially an amendment to the
Weimar Constitution which gives the
cabinet especially the Chancellor
effectively the Chancellor who's the
head of the cabinet legislative powers
unlimited legislative powers for the
next four years so it gives it gives
legislative powers and remember we
already have suspended civil rights so
the Reichstag is essentially giving over
the legislative power legislative powers
to to the Chancellor who happens to be
who happens to be Hitler and there was
some check on this by the president but
then we have Hindenburg dying the next
year but after this after the suspension
of civil rights and then the enabling
act shortly afterwards
Hitler is essentially in full control
Hitler and the Nazis are essentially in
full control of the German government
and at this point Hitler is the dictator
the dictator of he is the dictator of
Germany and they start to act fast they
start to intimidate other parties they
they use violence they start to imprison
people and by July of 1933 so they're
acting very very fast by July of 1933
Nazis are the only legal party only
legal pop party and they essentially
have full control now this is how Hitler
came to power and now the question
that's probably circling in your mind is
who did this fire this fire was the
catalyst although Hitler was already
Chancellor and maybe he would have found
some way to get to power regardless but
this fire even though there was
evidence that look like maybe marinus
van der Lubbe did it it was blamed on
the communists it was the pretext that
was used to give the the government even
more power especially the the Nazis even
more power this is an open question one
of those great open questions one of
those great open questions of history
some people feel that maybe it was just
a a communist plot maybe it was marinus
van der Lubbe acting on his own and and
maybe it just happened to fall into the
hands of Hitler and they were able to
use it while other historians think that
this was actually a plot by the Nazis to
kind of create this emergency state and
marinus van der Lubbe was just kind of a
puppet in this in this whole plot so
open question of history but needless to
say as we go from 1919 to 1933 Hitler
goes from a fairly unknown individual to
full dictator of Germany